ça fait longtemps que je voulais faire
des combats de boxe est-ce que malgré
tout ça reste du sport bien sûr c'est le
fédération française qui a derrière
c'est organisé il ya une structure tout
est carré c'est pas on va pas finir dans
un aéroport à stabaek des bouteilles de
parfum je tiens à le dire ces mots
précis un ami
ben est un génie nous attentions bien
sûr non on ne fera pas ça en tout cas et
chercher un adversaire et j'ai fait un
appel de ma story et benji a été le
premier à répondre présent du coup je ne
les combattez avec castres où son casque
sans casque et sans casque d'accord que
boxeur gresin boxe anglaise vous vous
entraînez en ce moment ouais deux fois
par jour ou deux fois par jour quatorze
fois par semaine alors ça va ça commence
à apprendre ben ça va petit à petit un
petit talon pas un petit peu à wayne se
voir ta garde à savoir la garde
ces toilettes avant la fin du mois bon
allez pas mal c'est vrai ouais mais
c'est du coup qu'ils sont puissants
comment tu te sens très bien tu
t'entraînes aussi tous les jours ma deux
fois par jour ça suce 2 0 où avant ils
avaient déjà fait de la boxe en java on
est on est deux sportifs malgré tout m
et ils ont géré
dylan avait fait de la base quelques
leçons on va pas mentir comme une anti
sur sa taille il avait déjà fait de la
boxe il a fait quelques leçons moi
jamais j'ai commencé le 9 mars et
d'entraînement jeudi à deux semaines et
demie d'entraînement je me demande où
tous les jours comment tu t'es vendre
une queen toit très bien ouais non mais
je me sens bien je me sens bien j'ai
quand même bien chez avec le meilleur
entraîneur de france encore tu
t'entraînes avec qui avec louis lavaly
d'accord et toi avec motech d'accord il
mottaki les paliers venus d'ailleurs
moment il est là je verrai tout à
l'heure ok
c'est sérieux on est loin du palais des
sports et bouquets ya combien de
personnes ont parlé d'espoir cession
atteint 5,7 1500 personnes et gagne quoi
le vainqueur alors carte est justement
le vainqueur je crois que vous combattez
pour une association aussi ouais la
mienne d'accord d'accord très bien et
vous pour son association aussi mauvais
pour ma part moi c'est un titre
personnel d'accord vous êtes vous êtes
payés donc enfin le combat exactement
alors qu'on prenne pas des coups dans la
gueule pourrait bien sûr mais après
c'est un business comme celui d'un
business qu'est ce que l'on pensé
combien les droits payés combien il va
pas nous dire c'est pas du tout
c'est pas encore ça va dépendre la
billetterie je pense belge après rien
rappeur view vient ppp review qui est
qui vient d'être en place ça y est
d'accord que fine chaîne d'accord chez
fin qui nous a contactés aussi c'est à
dire quand même action mais pour faire
quoi pour tes fixe plutôt telfix exact
mais c'est quelque chose de très très
sérieux c'est quelque chose de sérieux
on n'est pas en guerre à la base mais
sur le ring ça va être ça sorte sans
pitié sans pitié d'accord on a fini loin
pour pâques le mettre ko direct ménard
message qu'on l'attend le combat
forcément acquis au resto trouver ça
trop violent non moi je trouve ça bien
c'est vrai que ça se fait beaucoup à
l'étranger en france on a un malaise
avec ça ça fait penser à boubacar et que
ça avait du mal à organiser le combat
parce qu'il n'y a pas deux ni avait peu
de médias qui voudrait diffuser est-ce
que vous avez du mal à trouver quelqu'un
pour diffuser ce combat où il organisait
la suite ou non au contraire c'est très
facile tout s'est fait automatiquement
ça a été a été caressée aujourd'hui on a
des demandes de gauche à droite en fait
à partir du moment où il a lancé son
appel sur les réseaux moi quand j'ai
répondu je connaissais déjà un
organisateur de gala de boxe il nous a
intégré à ce maniaque qui était déjà qui
était déjà prévu l'accord il nous
intégrer un combat en plus pour nous et
après de fil en aiguille vu qu'on en a
parlé sur les réseaux mais là forcément
il ya des gens qui sont proposés pour
nous diffuser que c'est vrai ça s'est
fait très rapidement d'accord oui et
delphine vous êtes des influenceurs très
suivi est ce que justement vous avez
vapeur que les jeunes reproduit ça sent
les règles de la boxe juste parce qu'ils
ne s'aiment pas concrètement vous êtes
leurs modèles donc est-ce que vous avez
réfléchi à ça benjamin moi pour ma part
la différence c'est que nous on ne se
détestent pas on n'est pas en embrouille
on ne monte pas sur un ring pour régler
un différend c'est un défi sportif c'est
un sportif et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que j'ai relevé le défi parce que je
sais que c'est un très grand sportif je
le suis aussi dans ma vie tous les jours
j'ai fait beaucoup de sport et je veux
avant tout de donner une image de sport
alors bien évidemment il va y avoir des
coups c'est un peu violent bien sûr mais
la boxe à les barrettes sahara est un
sport noble infuser c'était diffusé sur
canal+ c'est toujours diffusée sur un
bus c'est toujours et encore on jouait
bien sûr bien sûr elle en a le combat
que tony key variés pas aussi un combat
de tony je sais qu'à l'époque moi je
avec mon grand-père on regardait tous
les soirs enfin quasiment tous les soirs
la boxe à télé aujourd'hui c'est un peu
plus dans londres on en parle moins il
ya des gens qui font ça toute la journée
mais qui regardaient pas en vivre donc
si on arrive nous avec cet événement là
à remettre un peu de lumière sur la boxe
anglaise qui est du sport avec des
règles que les jeunes nous suivent s'ils
suivent notre exemple à nous tant mieux
parce que c'est fait dans les règles de
l'art les six essais impression que j
excusez moi tous les deux mais pour moi
c'est une pitrerie et disant que c'est
moins cher que tu consultes tu
cautionnes pas la boxe mais tu
cautionnes quelqu'un qui traquent dans
une église n'ont déjà pas de logique toi
non aujourd'hui on utilise notre à notre
influence pour faire du sport sur tu vas
construit un mec qui turque dans une
église mais tu vas pas cautionner de
sportif qui monte sur un ring bravo ya
aucune logique dans ce que tu dis à
moulins sportive n'a aucune portée
[Applaudissements]
koné dit donne moi je trouve préfère je
préfère ça je trouve ça vraiment moi car
cette chance sachez quand même que
l'argent va aller une bonne association
trois jours trois jours après je pars en
voyage humanitaire pour récolter
l'argent que j'ai donné de ma sueur et
de ma transpiration et de mon visage
bonsoir des gersois qui sont boudés
c'est vous dérange c'est un show c'est
alors ben oui mais alors mais c'est fait
alors sa valeur il s'agissait pour moi
c'est via l'ordre et la boxe la boxe
mairie la boxe la boxe est un chômeur
mais on en a marre oui dans ce pot 1 et
au et la boxe
est un sport et c'est un show a besoin
vg bain mathieu sur pile quand on sait
que l'irak émission temps mais une la
boxe celle inverse des valeurs de la
haine justement exactement ray sports6
était détesté alors là j'aurais pas
cautionner s'il sert bien il fonça ghana
pour une assoc bien c'est encadré c'est
parfait autant boubakary c'était
discutable se détester la c1 vient
encore son iphone combat de boxe ou là
ils vont prendre la limite les mecs
direct voilà des règles comme l'était
c'est évidemment que c'est un show et
les spectateurs a bien sûr dans oui bien
sûr ouvert toute la semaine gilles en
fait comment ça se passe sur ds pas
possible parce qu'ils sont illégaux mais
je comprends pas matthieu delormeau
c'est plus qu'on vous dit
non ce que je trouve bien c'est que
justement on parle de sport et pas de m
bien sûr donc là ça vous le faites vous
dis bravo à tous les deux bien sûr c'est
moi au début je vais vous dire quand
j'ai vu ça je me dis mais qu'est ce que
c'est cette connerie encore ça me
plaisait pas mais là votre discours il
est intéressant vous parler de sport il
ya une assoc la seriat n'y a pas de
haine bravo pour ma part personnellement
moi ça fait des années que je fais de la
télé away que je fais partie un peu du
milieu de l' influence est jamais eu
besoin d'avoir un clash avec un autre
candidat ou de m'afficher sur les
réseaux sociaux a insulté qui que ce
soit ou me faire insulter pour arriver
où j'en suis là donc c'est pas
aujourd'hui avec un combat de boxe
anglaise encadrée par des lois par une
règle que je vais aujourd'hui m'afficher
non ça se fait ça c'est dans le respect
tant mieux et si on peut donner une
bonne image de la bassure qu'il ya des
interdits valant élimination ne sus vous
ai pas le droit de faire
la peinture est pas parce qu il ya des
choses qu'ils n'ont pas le droit de
laisser les règles de l'art excuse bien
sûr la balle dehors
c'est comme au tennis n'a pas le droit
de faire votre place et remixés on n'a
pas besoin de regarder mais pas du tout
par exemple on n'a pas le droit de taper
en dessous de la scène sera bien sûr bah
oui c'est sûr que si elle a les cheveux
les règles de la sueur non pour moi ça
c'est le coucher aux premiers rôles très
bien c'est que dès le départ vous avez
dit que vous étiez pas ennemis
effectivement vous avez lever cette
ambiguïté mais c'est pas un règlement de
compte soit là pour vous crêper le
chignon est donc ça c'est parce que je
trouve que c'est un bon exemple ensuite
le sport moi je trouve que c'est génial
parce que ça sert d'ascenseur social a
[Applaudissements]
pas vu cela
qui va défier la reine mary decker
mais
là c'est tout dire de partout j'adore
c'est super pour les jeunes vous regarde
après vous ne la fait pas à l'envers non
plus vous dites on va faire de la
lumière sur la box non vous fait la
lumière sur vous parce que je pense que
c'est la mort de la téléralité des
influences
rabat joie et je pense que vous avez
aussi mémoire mais moi je pense que
c'est un truc bien c'est un nouveau truc
je pense ça va être un nouveau truc qui
va cartonner ça sur six états unis mais
je vous le dis ça va être le premier à
vous regardez donc ça on verra si tu
veux venir au palais des sports ce soir
là ces noms là sa venue bon franchement
c'est avec les avocats de fortis est pas
un peu vos entrées c'est qu'ils
s'aperçoivent règne en battant mais je
me suis entraîné
j'ai demandé à l'inde de mission de
faire de faire un petit de faire un
petit combat contre moi et ils veulent
pas personne est morte acceptera en
combat un
beau gâchis
si arthur me regarde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime ça j'aime beaucoup mais je doute
qu'ils veuillent bien martèle à 60 ans
est ce que tu accepterais contre un mec
jeunes et gauche mais oui bah si on
donne de l'argent oui non non non mais
pour une association un truc à moi je
trouve que c'est un beau truc c'est un
truc je voulais organiser il voulait
faire aussi avec des potes je trouve que
moi c'est après benjamin et voilà il va
y va il le fait voilà parce qu'il va
prendre un cachet moi je comprends sur
dylan il le fait pour une association je
trouve que c'est ça super aussi voilà
moi je trouve que je préfère les voir
dans sur un ring de boxe comme ça un peu
plus tôt sur un train de s'insulter de
se battre à la télé pour ils ont fait
les examens clocher qui sont insultés
exactement ce sont les deux essais sur
les réseaux au final ils se croisent
très divertissant poizat est à la fois
que j'allais vous tomber dans les bras
tous les domaines bien sûr ça va être un
bon ça reste de signes de rien
exactement je vous sers
tu bats et pourrait-il moins cher ce qui
n'empêche pas des gens
il faut pas non mais tu m'a écouté ou
pas j'ai dit que c'est formidable parce
que justement le sport cet ascenseur
social et c'était très belle et très bon
exemple si le design est
une forme d'art mais battu banshee trois
abattoirs mais j'étais sûr il est sûr
car il s'intitule le demanderaient
serment qui brille sur kim alors
attendez attendez ils sont allés chéri
est ce que est ce que les cherry on peut
parier oui mais les paris qui soit
ouvert je ne crois pas que ce soit que
ce soit en place achetée sinon là ça va
être un bordel je pense après c'est que
après selon comment ça se passe si et
quand je vais le mettre ko d'un mondial
c'était truqué mais ça va être bon et
vous n'avez pas peur de vous abîmez
visage non ça c'est le jour hing c'est
que non bah oui je mets ce qu'il a quand
même aussi beaucoup joué de la plastique
ouais ça chauffe à risque aussi s'il ya
pas de plastique la foulée don
cherry est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
une petite démo à pourvoir un petit peu
ce que ça a donné les cours depuis le
début est-ce que momo tech et la
madine coach vas-y à l'hormadi
[Musique]
hamon mottaki si après
ça va aussi rida moi
[Applaudissements]
comment tu le sens bien ben allez savoir
qu'il est venu s'entraîner donc il est
sorti de dubaï pour venir chênois beau
dans le 77 et la tuque au quartier ouais
voilà ça dans mon chéri toi ça va et
quoi qu'ils aient fait plaisir à tout va
et c'est un grand champion tech merci
d'être là
et
nazis alors il ya une différence voir
que tu as vu de taille c'est la
différence est que amar je n'avais
jamais fait de leçons avant le 9 mai
non mais je montre ce que je sais faire
mais j'ai commencé il ya deux semaines
d'accord ah oui c'est votre cours j'ai
coincé
[Musique]
je suis inquiet
on s'est regardé mon mémoire je connais
un petit peu voilà voilà ouais t'as eu
par mois là et octobre 2000 quand même
des gens il a travaillé que dix jours de
gravité assez bas
on sait tout de suite et lui les plus
grands domaines à bouger cinq ans un
conseil et après on pressent pour toi
annule
[Applaudissements]
alors on va faire le tour et on n'a pas
le tour vous vous doutiez moi j'y crois
d'accord oui idem benjamin oui
oui elle à force de penser faut
visualiser donc ce n'est pas joué
d'avancé
la force
tranquille je ne sais pas qui est cette
personne là votre guilde va le
pulvériser oui je mets jamais 100% mais
benjamin way benjamin blain billet sur
dida de ma couille
[Applaudissements]
je donne mon avis embrayant du mot pour
l'instant de ce que j'ai vu benjamins
pour l'instant il a un petit peu de
boulot voilà mais si rien et ça va faire
il va bosser s'agit d'un fake deux sont
âgés l'avancé avec deux semaines
exactement sion pour l'instant c'est
l'outsider voilà je pense